[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Hi, everybody.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Hello.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Hi.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: How's it going?
We're going to do
some improv for you.
All we need to get started is a
suggestion of anything at all.
What?
SPEAKER 1: Google.
[LAUGHTER]
KELSEY BAILEY: Uh oh.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Google.
Thank you.
I heard Google.
[LAUGHTER]
[TONGUE CLICKING]
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Hey, guess what, guys.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Oh?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: I
got some Gmail invites.
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLINE MARTIN: Yeah?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Yeah.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: You
guys want some Gmail invites?
CAROLINE MARTIN: Yeah,
I'll take a couple.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah,
it's pretty exclusive.
You need to be invited.
MICHAEL HARTNEY:
Uh, it's 2019, man.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: What?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: I--
I've been on Google--
I've been on Gmail
for, like, 15 years.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Well--
well, how come I have these--
how come I have these invites?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Because
your-- you must be new.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Oh, OK.
So how long have
you been on Gmail?
CAROLINE MARTIN: Like,
maybe five years?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: What?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: What?
CAROLINE MARTIN: I was a Yahoo--
I was Yahoo ride or die,
and then they said, no more.
[LAUGHS] So I had to
upgrade a little bit.
Guys, I would love
to sit down, but you
know that I'm not allowed.
I'll see you later.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Why is
she not allowed to sit down?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: I
think she mentioned
Yahoo a bunch in her interview.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Oh, right.
MICHAEL HARTNEY:
They frown on that.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Man, I need to catch up
if I'm-- if I--
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Yeah, how
are you allowed to sit?
You just got Gmail?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: I--
I'm the kid of the owner.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Oh.
Wait, you're Derek Google?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
Junior.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Well,
welcome aboard, man.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Well, yeah.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: So all of
this other email servers, that
was like childlike rebellion?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Yeah, I never
used email or any sort of
electronic or digital thing.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: This is
your first email address?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Yeah.
How did you do anything at all?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: I would
call people on the phone.
I would visit them in person.
I would write letters.
I would stalk them.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL HARTNEY: This is the
longest conversation I've
had with a person in decades.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
KELSEY BAILEY: All
right, have a seat.
Listen, you could walk
out of this interrogation
room a free man.
All you got to do is let us
see your Google search history.
LOU GONZALEZ: Put
me away forever.
[LAUGHTER]
Put me away forever, because
I'm not going to do it.
KELSEY BAILEY: All you gotta
do is hand over your phone.
We just got to look at your
last 72 hours of search history,
maybe check out your
Google location.
LOU GONZALEZ: It's
not really about
my own individual
privacy, it's just--
I don't want to be embarrassed--
[LAUGHTER]
KELSEY BAILEY: I understand.
LOU GONZALEZ: Because
I will be embarrassed.
KELSEY BAILEY: I understand.
LOU GONZALEZ: I don't
clean my history.
I'm stupid.
[LAUGHTER]
KELSEY BAILEY: Well,
looks like you're looking
at life behind bars, then.
LOU GONZALEZ: Cool.
I'm fine with that, as long
as no one sees my history.
KELSEY BAILEY: All right, fine.
I'll make a deal with you.
LOU GONZALEZ: Cool.
KELSEY BAILEY: I won't look
at your Google search history,
but I do need to look at your
drafts folder in your Gmail.
LOU GONZALEZ: No.
What?
There-- oh, man.
I don't clear that at all.
KELSEY BAILEY: No
one knows how to.
We all forget that it exists.
LOU GONZALEZ: Yeah.
What if I show
you the last five?
KELSEY BAILEY:
Drafts or searches?
LOU GONZALEZ: The
drafts, because really, I
don't know what's there.
And once I get a gauge
of what's happening,
I could then make a decision.
[LAUGHTER]
KELSEY BAILEY: Cool.
Pull up your phone.
LOU GONZALEZ: All right.
OK.
All right, so this is a--
Hey.
Hi.
What's up?
What happened yesterday?
I miss you.
OK, so far, so good.
KELSEY BAILEY: Who were these
emails intended to go to?
LOU GONZALEZ: Um--
KELSEY BAILEY: The victim?
Chastity Bono?
LOU GONZALEZ: No, a lot of
these are different people.
I don't know, like
you could literally
look at the people who--
so this is-- this is for my mom.
That's I miss you.
I don't contact her much,
so I feel guilty about it.
And so I always start a draft,
and I'm like, you know what?
She's going to judge me.
I'm not going to
send this email.
So I choose not
to send the email.
I have a lot of that.
A lot of, like, I miss you.
Let's catch up.
Because she'll read
an email, but she
doesn't respond
to text messages--
that doesn't make sense.
It's wild.
KELSEY BAILEY: OK.
I'm going to close that.
LOU GONZALEZ: OK.
So I'm good to go?
This was fine.
KELSEY BAILEY: No, sit down.
You're still being
charged for murder.
LOU GONZALEZ: What?
Still?
KELSEY BAILEY: Those drafts!
[APPLAUSE]
CAROLINE MARTIN: Everybody--
everybody, I want everyone
to feel empowered to
pitch ideas for how
animate the little
Google guy every day.
Now I'm going to start, because
y'all never take my ideas,
but I want to turn it around.
I think there should be a little
cat with a little horn that's
just like boop, boop, boop.
And he has nothing
to do with what's
happening in the calendar, but
just a little boop, boop, boop,
boop.
Wouldn't that be fun?
Google-- boop, boop, boop.
Right, guys?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
I-- you know,
I think one reason we
don't take your ideas
is we don't quite understand
what you're talking about.
CAROLINE MARTIN: OK,
so, like, so, OK.
So there are cats.
Those are big.
A kitten's smaller.
A horn-- they're smaller.
And then a little horn--
it's a brass instrument,
but it's going to be small.
LOU GONZALEZ: We
understand the words
in the sentences you said.
We understood that.
We just didn't
understand how it applied
to the animations of the--
CAROLINE MARTIN: Got it.
I'll bring it home.
OK, so--
LOU GONZALEZ: Please do.
CAROLINE MARTIN: When you think
about joy and opportunity,
don't you think of a kitten
who's empowered itself
to learn a musical instrument?
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL HARTNEY: No one's
ever thought that once.
CAROLINE MARTIN: OK, but
I think that's the truth
of the situation.
But you know what?
Let's just put that--
let's just--
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Let's table it.
CAROLINE MARTIN: OK, OK.
Put it on the table.
KELSEY BAILEY: I have an idea.
CAROLINE MARTIN: OK.
Let's do it.
KELSEY BAILEY: OK,
so close your eyes.
CAROLINE MARTIN: OK.
KELSEY BAILEY: We'll think
about joy one more time.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: OK.
KELSEY BAILEY: All
right, here we go.
I've made a little
illustration we'll
put up on the SMART Board.
Right there.
LOU GONZALEZ: Right.
Do I open--
KELSEY BAILEY: Open your eyes.
It's a futon eating nachos.
LOU GONZALEZ: Oh.
KELSEY BAILEY: That's fun.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: What?
CAROLINE MARTIN: I don't get it.
KELSEY BAILEY: OK,
well think about--
OK, a futon is somewhere
that you go to relax.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Yes.
KELSEY BAILEY: But what
does a futon do to relax?
It eats nachos.
Nachos are a traditionally
Mexican dish that--
CAROLINE MARTIN:
No, we get nachos.
We get the nachos.
KELSEY BAILEY: Corn chips--
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
We know what it is.
Again, we know all the words
that were in the sentence
that you just said, but it feels
like a lot of the suggestions
that are coming up are very
specific to the individual that
is suggesting them.
CAROLINE MARTIN: OK.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Right?
CAROLINE MARTIN: All right.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Like you love kittens.
You love nachos.
KELSEY BAILEY: Futons.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Oh, OK.
Futons.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe we can try to think
a little bit more broadly.
MICHAEL HARTNEY:
I've gotten an idea.
I've got an idea.
LOU GONZALEZ: All
right, bring it, Barry.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Come on, Barry.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: So
instead of Google, it'll
say, yeah, great job
this quarter, Barry.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
There will be a ram,
because I'm an Aries.
So then the ram will come
in, and it'll be like,
Barry is handsome.
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLINE MARTIN: OK.
OK, well--
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
OK, again--
CAROLINE MARTIN:
Very specific to you.
KELSEY BAILEY: Specific, yeah.
CAROLINE MARTIN: How
did you get that idea?
Could you just
take us through it?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: So
the signs of the zodiac
are an astrological--
CAROLINE MARTIN: No,
we know what that is.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHAEL HARTNEY: I just
want to be celebrated more.
CAROLINE MARTIN: OK.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: So--
CAROLINE MARTIN: Well, OK.
I'll apologize for that.
I can-- I will write that down.
LOU GONZALEZ: Barry,
I appreciate you,
and I apologize I
haven't celebrated you.
MICHAEL HARTNEY:
Are we tabling mine?
KELSEY BAILEY: I
think we should.
CAROLINE MARTIN:
We should table it.
KELSEY BAILEY: I
definitely think we should.
[APPLAUSE]
LOU GONZALEZ: E, Z,
O, P, N, W, Q, R.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Good, good, goo.
LOU GONZALEZ: T, W, X!
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
We can stop there.
LOU GONZALEZ: Z!
OK.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah,
when I say stop, we can stop.
LOU GONZALEZ: All right.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: OK.
And now, the letters
are going to be smaller.
So just let me know--
LOU GONZALEZ: Yeah, I'm
going to fucking crush this.
It's cool.
E, W, Z, R, Q.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
OK, let's do that again.
LOU GONZALEZ: OK.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Yeah, let's do it again.
LOU GONZALEZ: I
didn't crush that?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: No.
LOU GONZALEZ: All right.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
LOU GONZALEZ: E, M, O, S, P,
square, dot, dot, M, P, W--
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
OK, let's pause.
Yeah, there are no shapes
or dots on the sheet.
Yeah, I think
we're going to need
to upgrade your prescription.
I know you were
feeling a little bit--
LOU GONZALEZ: I studied
so hard for this.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: I know
you were feeling a little bit
self-conscious about that.
LOU GONZALEZ: I just--
I just don't want to have
the level of prescription
where it makes my eyes smaller.
I don't want that.
I'm never going to get that.
I'd rather be blind.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: No,
it's not a big deal, OK?
It's just a little bit
thicker of glasses.
LOU GONZALEZ: I just don't
want to hear anything
about these assholes at work.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: OK.
LOU GONZALEZ: All right?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Do
they-- do your employees
always fun of you?
LOU GONZALEZ: No, it's
a fear that I have.
I'm pretty-- as a boss, it's--
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Hey.
LOU GONZALEZ: Hey.
No!
MICHAEL HARTNEY:
New prescription?
You got a tiny,
little eyes, baby!
Baby.
KELSEY BAILEY: I love
the lunches here.
Oh my god.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Me too.
Maybe I'll-- get a little.
[LAUGHTER]
KELSEY BAILEY: Are we being bad?
CAROLINE MARTIN:
We're being bad.
Hey, girlfriend.
I feel like we're bonding.
So I'm going to be real real.
I don't work here.
I know, right?
I just got in.
Yeah.
It's funny.
If you just take any ID and you
swipe it confidently, and then
look back and go,
they'll open the gate.
KELSEY BAILEY: You fired
four people this morning.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Yeah, I did.
Yeah.
I'm empowering myself.
Look at this pasta.
KELSEY BAILEY: It's very good.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Pasta
during the day-- who are we?
KELSEY BAILEY: I'm sorry.
I-- this is--
I'm a little taken aback.
I feel like I should tell
security that you're here.
CAROLINE MARTIN:
No, no, no, no, no.
KELSEY BAILEY: I
never want to stop--
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Somebody call for security?
KELSEY BAILEY: Um.
Gary what would happen
if someone was wandering
the building and they did
not have the right to be here
and they also fired
four people from a team?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: OK.
I'm actually not sure,
because I don't work here.
Yeah, no, you just
called me Gary.
But yeah, we met this morning.
And I introduced myself.
But I don't work here.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Me too!
I don't work here.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Free coffee?
CAROLINE MARTIN: I know!
Snackies.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
I'm being bad.
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLINE MARTIN: OK.
KELSEY BAILEY: Yeah.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Boing, boing,
boing, boing, boing, boing,
boing, boing.
They have so many toys here.
KELSEY BAILEY: Hey, Barry.
How are you doing?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: I'm
good, how are you?
KELSEY BAILEY: Good.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Lunchtime!
KELSEY BAILEY: Yeah.
Hey, Barry, what would happen
if someone snuck in here-- two
people snuck in
here-- one pretending
to be security for a large
company and another person
acting as a CEO firing people?
MICHAEL HARTNEY:
Oh, well, let me
consult my employee handbook.
Psych!
I've never worked here!
KELSEY BAILEY: Barry!
We made you a Google!
You were in a Google animation.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: I know!
It was such a coup.
KELSEY BAILEY: Am I
the only person who
actually works at Google here?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Yeah, what you do here?
CAROLINE MARTIN: Yeah.
What do you do?
KELSEY BAILEY: I put
on corporate events,
make sure that
there's team bond--
LOU GONZALEZ: Hey,
how's everything going?
Derek Google here.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Oh.
The Derek-- Derek?
Wow, it's Derek Google.
LOU GONZALEZ: I'm
taking all this food.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: He starts from
the other side of the line.
LOU GONZALEZ: How's it going?
KELSEY BAILEY: Good.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Going good.
KELSEY BAILEY: Mr. Google Jr.,
I have a question for you.
Say a company of 458
people didn't actually
work in the building that they
were showing up to and rather
they were just sort of
breaking in and acting
as if they worked here.
What-- what would happen?
LOU GONZALEZ: Oh, fuck!
Do, do, do!
CAROLINE MARTIN: [SCREAMS]
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Holy shit.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Oh.
Let's get some chairs.
KELSEY BAILEY: Oh, we're done.
LOU GONZALEZ: All right.
Team work.
SPEAKER 2: Well, thank
you so much, everyone.
So funny and great way to start.
LOU GONZALEZ: Great suggestion.
KELSEY BAILEY: Yeah.
Thank you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LOU GONZALEZ:
Yeah, it's probably
one of the best suggestions
I've ever gotten.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Probably the
lowest hanging fruit.
So just for people who have
never seen improv before,
if you could just describe
a little bit of what
are the main guidelines
or like major points
of how to-- how does this work?
How do you sort of create
something in the moment?
Michael, do you want to start?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Sure.
Fun.
So long form improv is
usually about taking
a single suggestion and doing
a longer form, like, you've
seen "Whose Line Is
It Anyway", where they
do short little improv games.
But at UCB, we do longer scenes.
And you use the
tentative "yes, and?"
We explore an unusual thing.
We react to that unusual thing.
We build ideas together.
And then we heighten and
explore, is what we call it.
SPEAKER 2: So what does
that mean to, like, heighten
and explore, like
if you want to--
MICHAEL HARTNEY: So for
example, the lunch line scene,
that scene heightened by
the world kept expanding.
We found out that
even Derek Google Jr.
himself did not work
at Google, which
was a heightening from
Caroline not working at Google.
We thought she was weird.
Turns out every-- turns
out she was weird.
KELSEY BAILEY: Yeah.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So Kelsey,
we mentioned this
is long form improvisation.
And we know that there's
short form, which is probably
something people know
from college improv
groups and television.
What are some other forms,
and what do they all
have in common as
one thing, as--
KELSEY BAILEY: Sure.
Other forms of improv
are just, yeah-- well,
I think for any type
of improv, whether it's
short form or long
form, just being
on board with whoever
you're on stage with is
the key to any type of
improv that you're doing.
Whether it's a short
form game where you all
are playing crazy
characters, because you're
supporting that person you're
going to be set up for success.
It's the people who might
not be able to appreciate
an idea that's being pitched
to them by their teammate
or not listening, by
being in agreement,
being on each other's side,
and both working together
to be able to build something,
whether it's a scene, or just
a short improv game,
is probably the thing
that they all have in common
to be able to succeed.
SPEAKER 2: So what
are some qualities
of teams and teammates that make
it work, that are important,
that you look for, or that
you try to bring to your team
as you're performing?
Caroline?
CAROLINE MARTIN: Sure.
I would say trust.
I know that I can try
something out, give it a whirl,
and that someone has
my back and they'll
help me see this idea through.
Or if I start with a half
idea and my scene partner
or teammate can see in my eyes
that I'm, like, I'm not sure.
I'm just throwing this out.
And knowing that they're going
to see it through with me
and have my back and support
me is really important to me.
SPEAKER 2: That's great.
So does anyone
else have something
that's important to
them in their teams?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
I think embracing everybody's
strengths is really important.
Because each
individual performer
brings in kind of their
unique set of skills
and their sense of humor.
And anytime that
you're just making
that other person
correct and true,
it makes the work of
improv a lot easier.
Because then you're
not having to fight,
two people having to
be funny at each other,
they can be funny together.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
Yeah.
So there's a very
common improv saying
that you need to make
your partner look great.
So sometimes, like,
as a performer,
it might sound like a
little counterintuitive.
The point is to put on a big
show, to shine, to be funny.
But in improv, it's, like, put
the emphasis on your partner.
So do you want to describe--
how does that work
to the benefit of both people?
LOU GONZALEZ: I try not
to make them look good.
I want to stand out.
[LAUGHTER]
But it actually is.
It's just about
communication, really.
It's all about yes, anding.
I need my scene partner to be
on board with what's going on.
And in order for them to
truly be in sync with me,
I also have to accept
them for everything
that they're bringing
to the table, as well.
And so it's one of those
things a lot when I teach,
you see little micro no's.
And you see how it impacts how
the scenes progress sometimes.
SPEAKER 2: What do you
mean by micro no's?
LOU GONZALEZ: Like
someone will say,
I can't believe you
did x, y, and z.
Because a lot of times,
especially in new classes,
people are, like, I'm
going to blame my scene
partner doing something.
And that immediately puts
them on the defensive.
It puts something
on them, rather
than accepting it not being.
And that's why we always say
like, oh, yes, and, and build.
And also do small things,
where it's cold outside.
It's, like, yeah,
but you know what?
I like how cold it is.
It's OK.
But someone said in a very
negative tone that it's cold.
And we're not necessarily
reciprocating that.
And so sometimes that in itself,
just that small interaction,
could impact how a
scene progresses.
Because it impacts how the
person feels about what's
going on in the scene.
And so small things like
that, when you're doing stuff.
I mean, when I
trust, after you've
been doing it for a while,
and you'd like trust people.
You just straight
up mess around.
That's why I brought out a
jetpack, because I was, like,
well, it doesn't matter.
I know that they all looked up.
When I did the job,
it's, like, cool.
I pull away, great.
Because I was just, like,
oh, I trust these people.
And that is something
that is sometimes
earned through experience.
But in improv, we
try to let you--
we'll have that for
everyone, in that sense.
SPEAKER 2: So what
if sometimes--
any one of you-- if you
are doing a scene or a show
with someone you
don't know as well,
or is not as
experienced as you are,
how do you sort of empower
them to shine the way you want
any scene partner to shine?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
The thing I always
tell students is
treat that person as
if they're like the greatest
improviser who ever lived.
Because you don't want to
be a jerk to the greatest
improviser who ever lived.
You want to make them look good.
So I just tell them
pretend like it's
the person you admire
the most or whoever.
It's like, oh, you're
improvising with the Dalai
Lama or something like that.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't want to undermine
the Dalai Lama's--
LOU GONZALEZ: He's so good.
It's crazy how good.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
You should see him do improv.
It's very enlightened.
But yeah, the goal is, I
think, to make that person
feel trusted in their ideas.
And then to try to build
and agree on something
together so that
you're not just trying
to be funny at the person.
There's another
saying we have in
improv where there are no
lead actors in an improv team.
We're all supporting actors.
And that should be
our mindset when
we're going into an improv set
where not one or two people
are carrying the set.
Everybody's pulling on
the same rope together.
CAROLINE MARTIN: I think
everyone fully believes that.
But I feel like you can
access truly being at ease.
I don't have to do
anything, because I
know anything I throw
out there someone
will say great I can help.
I will help you
with that premise.
I see the intention
of your initiation,
or how you wanted to start
that scene, and I'll help
you finish it off.
So I feel like eventually
you get to this place
where, when you're improvising,
you're just living and being
in the moment, easier
said than done.
But if everyone's supporting
each other, it's easy.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
And you're sort of, like you
said, they have an intention,
assuming that the person
you're working with
has some sort of idea that
they're trying to put forward
and assuming that they
know what they're doing.
And making them look just as
good as you know that they are.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Right.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
So here at Google, we also,
of course, work in teams.
We collaborate with other teams.
No one is on their own
doing something all day.
And even if you're not taking
Improv 101, which everyone
should, there are
some skills that
could be translated from
that to any type of work.
So what are things
that you found yourself
using in day-to-day life?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Listening.
LOU GONZALEZ: Yeah.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Listening
is super important in improv,
and it turns out, in life.
But I think improv made
me a better listener.
And being good at
listening makes
you better at being a person.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
And to like, go off
this specific thing.
Sometimes in classes, we
talk about active listening.
Which just means instead
of simply hearing
what the other person is saying,
hearing what they're saying,
but also digesting it so that
you can react to it honestly.
Rather than just,
like, OK, I'm going
to wait for this person to
finish so I can say my thing.
That's not listening.
That is just competing
with the other person
to get the funny thing out.
But yeah, listening should
lead to some sort of reaction
off what they just said.
SPEAKER 2: So I bet
this is something
that's a little, like,
you don't think of it now.
And it's a lot more natural.
But so when you're listening,
what are you're trying to do?
What is your goal while you're
listening to somebody else
speak, when you're
active listening?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: I think
it's just to react honestly.
I think that's our one
goal in that moment.
Yeah.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: They're
also giving information
that you don't have.
Because a scene can't
exist if it's being
driven by just one person.
So they're building
the scene in ways
you couldn't have imagined.
So you need all that
fuel for that scene.
KELSEY BAILEY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So listening
is one major thing
that I think we all see that
people can do better at.
Are there other skills
that you've encountered?
KELSEY BAILEY: I think--
CAROLINE MARTIN: Oops, sorry.
KELSEY BAILEY: Go ahead.
CAROLINE MARTIN: No.
I also just feel like
hearing someone's idea all
the way through and helping
them fully flesh it out,
if you will.
So I feel like "yes, and"--
if you really believe it, I
agree with what you're saying,
and I'm building off
of what you've said.
We might get to absurdity.
But generally,
someone feels safer
and heard when you
genuinely believe in them,
hear them out, and then
help them build that idea.
So I think how you
brainstorm, you
can also use a lot of tenants
of improv that, as well.
SPEAKER 2: So there's
yes and I hear you.
I'm building on your idea.
I'm not bringing
something completely new
just because you
have done talking.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Yeah.
And consciously making
it "yes, and" and not
its devilish cousin,
"yes, but", which feels,
like, yeah, I heard you.
But that's not
what I want to do.
That doesn't feel good.
So truthfully attacking.
listening to
someone's POV as yes,
I'll hear it all
the way through.
And then maybe at the end,
we might not practically
be able to do it, it may
not work in the budget.
But I am giving you
the space in the ground
to fully tell me exactly
what you're interested in.
I think that's really helpful.
KELSEY BAILEY: That's
almost exactly what
I was going to say.
Just the tenet of "yes, and."
Especially in my
work environment,
implementing "yes, and"
when managing people,
that people are coming in with
ideas who might be someone
that I managed, to let them
know they're being heard.
And it's very scary to
present a new idea to someone,
especially someone above you.
So I mean, like, yes, and let's
see how we can explore this.
And even if it moves away
from the original idea,
because you know in
your brain, like,
oh, they're never going
to let us do that.
We don't have the freedom
to do that, right?
It's still like
exploring and showing
that you appreciate the person
who came to you with an idea
to try and help you achieve
whatever goal it is.
SPEAKER 2: Your goal
is to help them make
whatever is possible a reality.
Yeah.
So what are some--
if you were playing
with different groups--
and I've seen all of you
in different configurations
at the theater performing
with different people--
do you find that when you're
with a different group
of people, you play one role.
Not being a character, but like
a part, a utility on the team,
and then with
another group you're
doing something
completely different.
Do you find that that
happens to you sometimes?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
I think that at
least for me, I feel
the better you know your
team the more comfortable
you are with them.
So on the team that I
regularly play with,
we're all very good friends.
So that gives us
kind of some license
to screw around with
each other and do things
that are a little bit riskier.
Whereas if you're doing an
improv jam or something, where
it's a mix of different levels--
SPEAKER 2: What
is an improv jam?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
An improv jam
is you put your
name in a bucket.
And if you've never done
improv before you can do that.
And yeah, just a bunch of
different levels of improvisers
jamming together
on an improv stage.
SPEAKER 2: Everyone
comes onstage and just--
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
And yeah, sometimes
they'll be a drunk person.
Sometimes there will be--
LOU GONZALEZ: Sometimes
there will be a drunk person.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Usually
But Yeah, I think the
better you know somebody
and the more you--
I think it's just a baseline
level of trust and comfort
and experience with your
team, the more you're
willing to take riskier moves.
Whereas with more of like
an improv jam setting,
it's you're trying to
be polite to people.
You're trying to be
in your best behavior,
but probably your ceiling
isn't as high as an improviser
when you're in that setting.
SPEAKER 2: You're
playing a role there
as an experienced
improviser, trying
to sort of rein it in and make
it like make sense, maybe.
Help out.
Is that something that you
will do in other scenarios
like try to achieve certain
goals for yourselves
or for your show?
LOU GONZALEZ: I think each
scenario speaks to things
differently.
I think it's about just
assessing that when
you're there.
Because sometimes I'll assume
that a certain type of show
is going to happen.
But you can't predict that.
I can never predict how an
improv show is going to go.
Sometimes the most entertaining
times I've had on stage,
I was just, like, oh, boy,
it's going to be weird.
There's this weird
energy around.
Sometimes, like, you'll feel it.
Sometimes the worst
shows I've ever done,
I was, like, oh, boy,
what's happening?
And sometimes you feel it.
And then you're just, like,
everyone's just like brr.
Because improv is so much about
just connecting with someone.
And especially if
everyone's bright--
no one comes every day with
their brains functioning
the same, just like there's so
many different outside forces.
And when you're doing improv,
that shows very clearly,
like if something's
cluttered in your brain.
You either are
unencumbered by improv
and you play freely, or not.
A lot of it depends on what's
given to you a lot of times.
Like today, for instance.
I was like oh wow.
This is cool.
This is weird as shit.
I said to you.
And I was, like, this is weird.
I was, like, how do I don't
put myself in a situation
where I feel comfortable?
I performed for a weird
situation, the ambassador
of Denmark in Denmark.
And I remember, like,
with my group it was OK.
We're about to perform
for a bunch of dignitaries
for no reason.
[LAUGHTER]
And we do this exercise
where we huddled up
and we say that's
going to happen.
Just be, like, keeping
things positive--
and then I looked down and
we were all wearing sneakers.
And I was, like, this
is dumb, so dumb.
And then I think
like sometimes it's
about alleviating the
pressures that you
put on yourself so that you can
be open to what's happening.
Because yes, you can have that.
Like, yes, this is my role.
This is what I'm doing.
But you cannot let that
be your sole focus.
You have to just be
yourself, as well.
SPEAKER 2: How does what's
going to happen work?
How does that help you
get ready for a show?
LOU GONZALEZ: It's sort of just
putting positive energy out
there.
Just, like, we are going
to support each other.
And then everyone says
that's going to happen.
It's, like, we are going
to yes, and aggressively.
That's going to happen.
CAROLINE MARTIN:
LOU GONZALEZ: And I'm not going
to say shit, that happened.
[LAUGHTER]
So you want to keep it positive.
But then, like, things--
you know, life happens.
SPEAKER 2: That seems
like a great way
to start any scene, committee.
That's going to happen.
KELSEY BAILEY: I do do
it in personal things
when I need to amp
myself up, kind of, like,
getting an affirmation you
would do in the mirror.
If I have an interview
or something,
I'll be, like, you're
going to get this job.
That's going to happen.
And then I don't get it.
But it's OK.
[LAUGHTER]
It can still put you in
a positive head space.
And it's very empowering.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, that's awesome.
So I'm going to go back
to-- in the last year,
you've created
two shows that aim
to give underrepresented
groups in improv voice
and have these groups
perform different shows.
So I wanted to ask
you how did you
come up with these
shows and the classes,
and how did you shape those?
LOU GONZALEZ: I think it was--
I just wanted to create spaces
that I could confidently
speak in for my identity.
You know, I am a
queer person of color.
And so therefore,
last year I created
an all queer class
and an all POC class,
mostly for safe space.
The way-- you know, improv,
I love it, very white space.
But it's getting better.
But I wanted to just create a
space where people could just
be themselves.
And I was, like,
it'd be really cool.
It's Pride Month.
Let's do a queer show.
And I was, like, well,
I'm not just queer.
I'm POC.
So let me do a POC show.
And so that was just
the intent I'm just
going to do this thing.
Let's see what happens.
And I was blown away by the
scenes that I was seeing
and the camaraderie
that was developing
and the empowerment
that was happening just
by being with people who are
underrepresented, but felt
like they were in a safe space.
And that in itself created
such trust within each group
and created such
brave moves on stage.
And I think also
improv especially
is about a connection
with the audience.
And what we're giving
out, your receiving.
All that energy is being
shared back and forth.
You're following along with
the scene the same time we are.
You're discovering things
at the same time we are.
And when you align with a person
based on your own experiences,
based on how you view
the world, the closer
that is, the more you're
following that journey closely
and the more wonderful
that discovery becomes
when it's in line with your
understanding of what you want.
So sometimes people
laugh when you just
plainly state stuff that's
happening in an improv scene.
Like I was doing an eye test.
And just by doing the eye test,
I was getting small chuckles.
But like, it was
pretty evident what
it was but we're just
laughing because we're
affirming what's going on.
And it becomes
that much stronger
when it becomes more personal.
I think both of those
shows became very personal
for the people on
stage and connected
with people in the audience
on these very personal levels.
SPEAKER 2: And I've
seen both of those shows
and they were unbelievable and
super fun and really inspiring.
So thank you for those.
Yeah.
And every person
here on this panel
is involved in some show that
is giving a voice to a group
that they identify with, which
I think is really important.
And here at Google, like
any other organization,
we try to amplify
diversity, because everyone
knows how it improves the work
experience and the actual work
being done.
So I was wondering, Michael,
as the artistic director when
you schedule shows, how
do you let that guide you
when you're trying to
decide what's actually
being put on at the theater?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Sorry.
How do I let what guide me?
SPEAKER 2: Trying to
achieve diversity and--
MICHAEL HARTNEY:
Diversity, got it.
Sorry.
SPEAKER 2: --voices--
MICHAEL HARTNEY: I just want to
see a bunch of different voices
onstage.
Because I think that
hearing a bunch of shows
from the same type of
person over and over again,
it's monotonous.
And shows like-- we
do a show called Gay
by Play, where we do gay
commentary over improv scenes.
So there's no other
show like that.
You're not going to see a
different show like that.
And certainly like yeah,
Achilles frequently
does a show called
Asian AF, which
is a super funny
show that we wouldn't
have just a few years ago.
And I think the theater's
getting stronger
because so many different
stories are being told.
So I think about it a
lot when I'm programming.
SPEAKER 2: If anyone has any
questions for our performers,
feel free to line up.
There are mics on either side.
So we've talked a little
bit about different shows
at the theater.
So what are some
of the things that
are being programmed at UCB.
So you know that there's improv,
but what other types of shows?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Well,
there's sketch comedy.
We have some stand
up variety shows.
We have a storytelling show.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Sketch.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Did
I not say sketch?
CAROLINE MARTIN:
It's the first--
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Sketch.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Never mind.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Oh.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Listening!
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Yeah.
But mostly I would say our big
thing is improv and sketch.
SPEAKER 2: And sketch, yeah.
So where can people see
you guys, specifically,
at the theater regularly?
CAROLINE MARTIN: I
perform with The Curfew
every Saturday at 7:30
at UCB Hell's Kitchen,
as well as with my team
Astronomy Cloud, which is all,
you know, people of color.
And we perform
one Friday a month
at 10:30 at UCB
subculture, but you
can see that on the calendar.
So come on down.
It's real fun.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: I
do musical improv
with a team called
Rumple Teaser.
That is Mondays at 9:00
at UCB Hell's Kitchen.
And occasionally, you'll see me
throwing shade as part of Gay
by Play.
LOU GONZALEZ: I occasionally
throw shade at Gay by Play.
And I perform every
Friday at 7:30
with [INAUDIBLE]
at UCB Subculture.
KELSEY BAILEY: I
perform Tuesday nights
on Herald Night, which is one
of UCB's famous improv nights
with teams, on a
team called Reba.
And then I also am
on a show called Here
and Queer, which is an all queer
improv cast with special queer
storytellers the first Wednesday
of the month at 7:30 at UCB.
I'm so happy this is
here so I can remember.
UCB Hell's Kitchen.
[LAUGHTER]
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
I perform on Saturdays
at UCB Subculture with a
group called Airwolf at 8:30.
And then on the Sunday night
show at UCB Hell's Kitchen,
The Asscat 3,000 show, both.
Shows
SPEAKER 2: We have
some questions.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I'm curious about
when improv goes bad.
Have you ever had a case
where you had a yes,
but what the F did
this person just say?
Where you just
couldn't, you know,
because it was so horrible
or disgusting or shocking?
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: What
happens in that case?
KELSEY BAILEY: There is, like,
a beautiful mechanics to improv
that can allow you to get out
of a scene if you have to,
especially if it's
gone bad in a way you
saw us running in
front of scenes,
which is called an edit.
Which means that scene is over.
You can tag people out, like
with the tiny eyes scene.
So there's a lot of mechanics
to help be able to divert away
from something that is so
egregious that you're just
like I just can't see this
player on stage anymore.
Or again, we are working at
the top of our intelligence
and trying to even
make people who say
horrific things look better.
So I just, yeah.
I mean, lift them up, right?
There are ways that you can
try and take what they said
and make it work
through skills, as well.
AUDIENCE: I guess those are
the biggest opportunities, too,
for comedy?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Sometimes.
Sometimes.
LOU GONZALEZ:
People assume that.
Because they assume
that because something's
getting an immediate reaction,
that it's worth being comedic.
But actual good
comedy is something
that's earned and built.
Because a lot of times,
I'll get a lot of one
on one students who
just say really absurd
nonsense up top because they
want to be funny.
And the desire--
MICHAEL HARTNEY: Shocking.
--very shocking,
offensive stuff,
because it gets a reaction.
CAROLINE MARTIN: Reaction, yeah.
LOU GONZALEZ: And so they
look at that reaction,
like, well, any
reaction is good.
People are liking this.
And there's certain
human beings who
navigate this Earth
that just assume
a reaction is positive towards
them, no matter what it is.
I've seen them onstage.
I've performed
with some of them.
And those people tend
to not stick around
because that's not
comedy, unfortunately.
It's something, but I wouldn't
necessarily call it comedy.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY:
Yeah in my classes
I call them puppy
stomping laughs.
Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
And the reason I call them
that is, yeah, they're
moves that are made in the
scene purely for a reaction,
not for any sort
of comedic idea.
And we try to, as
Kelsey was saying,
try to play to the top of our
intelligence, which just means
do the smartest type
of scene you can
and react honestly to whatever
is going on in the scene.
And the way we deal with it when
it's coming at us from somebody
is we try to not sweep
it under the rug.
We try to react to it
honestly, call attention
to it so that we can deal
with it in a way that
is honest rather
than just being,
like, oh, I hope the
audience didn't see that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LOU GONZALEZ: Yeah.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Because
we know with the whole audience.
LOU GONZALEZ: Yeah,
you can't avoid that.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I guess I'll ask sort of the
opposite question of that.
I'm curious to hear about
some sketches that just went
fantastically well, especially
if they started from, maybe,
a seemingly pedestrian
or unfunny premise.
And then somehow they
got to this place
that was amazingly hysterical.
I'm just curious to hear
about some of those instances.
KELSEY BAILEY: Hm.
SPEAKER 2: Do you remember
a lot of scenes that you do?
LOU GONZALEZ: Man,
they're so ephemeral.
KELSEY BAILEY: Yeah.
MICHAEL HARTNEY: I can recall--
so we do this thing
every year called
the Del Close marathon, which
is tons of improv groups
do shows for literally
days and it's exhausting.
And my group was going
after a team of celebrities.
So the theater was packed.
And everyone was there
to see those celebrities.
And they did their show.
It killed.
They got off stage.
And we got on stage.
And they were, like,
you aren't famous.
Make me laugh.
They were not-- they didn't
want to like our show.
And we didn't let
it make us nervous.
We didn't let it
change how we play.
And we got 'em.
We got 'em good by the end.
[LAUGHTER]
Took a few minutes.
But yeah, we just relaxed and
built a great show together.
LOU GONZALEZ: In terms of,
like, a sketch or a scene
starting not in a
good place, I think
I'd say maybe 40% of my
scenes start with nothing.
And because it's
all about discovery,
and as long as you're listening
and adding and creating,
especially if you're
working on a sketch
and you think you
have the premise,
but the premise isn't
the focus of your scene,
you could discover
something else
that may be what's delightful
and joyful and entertaining
about that scene.
I think that happens
more than not, where
you're working on something.
I think some of the best
stuff that I've worked on
started pretty innocuous.
And I found that the things that
I was the most excited about,
ended up being OK.
Like of the things
that I've worked on,
like, nothing that
I started on was,
like, oh, man, this is
going to be the best thing
ever-- didn't end up
being the best thing ever.
And a lot of things where I
was, like, oh, this is fine.
I'm like, oh, wow,
this is great.
Oh!
It's sort of just about
the creative process.
And then building off of that.
And I think a lot of improv
is connected to that.
But also, writing and working
on sketches is like that.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
I think just to add
to that, I think
one experience
that we've all had
is performing for
out of town or places
that have never seen
any type of improv.
And this is just,
like, oh, what is this?
They have no idea
what it is walking in.
And yeah, it was like
Michael was saying.
You kind of just get them
within a few minutes.
They're like, oh,
this is what this is.
This is amazing.
And those are often
really gratifying.
CAROLINE MARTIN: I also am
thinking of a complicated start
to a show.
My team Astronomy Club,
again, all people of color,
we, for like a year
and maybe some change,
did a show called "Let's
Talk About Race, Baby",
where we interviewed the
audience about moments
that interacted with race,
more often than not negative,
of course.
And so we would get three or
four pretty intense stories
with upsetting content
that, as comedians, we
had to kind of sift
through it and see
what is our perspective
as comedians,
what has a charge on it.
How can we take this idea and
find something funny in it?
And being able to ride that wave
and find cathartic solutions
where the audience knew
what was the inspiration.
You know, police brutality--
absolutely not hilarious.
But if we have themes of that,
but it's played by ducks,
maybe we can get some laughs.
So that kind of matrix
of play, you know?
That's definitely not
a casual, have wine
before you improvise situation.
But as a comedian, for me,
that was really rewarding.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question
is, what do you do
to get you open to any ideas?
What do you study?
What do you prepare?
CAROLINE MARTIN: Oh.
Well, just to-- well,
I guess before--
LOU GONZALEZ: Just
to be open to ideas?
AUDIENCE: What do
you do, what do you
study to get some new
ideas, to be open,
to be open to any ideas?
Bizarre, or bad ideas,
any strange ideas?
LOU GONZALEZ: I think,
like, live a life.
That's so important.
Go out and engage with
the world and fail a lot.
Because failing is a
good experience to have.
And I think the more I
failed, the more empathetic
I became about
other human beings.
Because this existence is
weird, just in general, just
by navigating space.
And I think I became
more open to ideas
once I became more empathetic
to just people in general.
I feel like I'm a better
improviser because I've
grown as a person, not
only an improviser.
And you do that by
living, meeting people,
getting to meet people from
different aspects of life
than you.
And improv has helped me do
that by just going out and doing
stuff.
But also, just
navigating New York City.
You can meet a lot of
people in a short distance.
SPEAKER 2: We have time
for the last two questions?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Right.
First of all, thanks for
the talk and the show.
That was amazing.
And one thing I was
wondering was that you
mentioned a improv musical?
I was wondering, like,
how does that work?
Do you come up with music
and songs on the fly?
MICHAEL HARTNEY: We do.
It's crazy.
I still can't believe I do it.
Yeah.
The team that I'm
on was put together
by a musical director, a great
improviser, named Eric Gerson.
His big thing is that good
musical improv is just
good improv with music.
And he recruited a bunch
of people who'd never
done musical improv before.
I was-- I did not want to do it.
I thought it was terrifying.
And he said just
please just let me
work with you for three hours.
We'll teach you a few
different song structures.
And I think you'll
be good at it.
And so a bunch of
us got in this room.
He taught us a couple
of song structures.
And by the end of it,
we were doing things
that we had no idea that we
ever had the capacity to do.
And so now we do it every week.
And it's really fun.
So yeah, do what's scary to you.
You might be good at it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
That's amazing.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for being here.
Any tips or techniques
that you use
that would apply during
a scene or giving a toast
or having a conversation over
dinner, power of the pause
is an example I think
someone mentioned.
Stating the obvious, so I
guess it could make you funny
or make you charismatic
or just bring attention
to what you're saying.
CAROLINE MARTIN: I feel like
one of the most important parts
of general conversation
that I find
that my one-on-one students
have a hard time with,
which actually makes you a
good listener and charismatic,
is showing someone that you
care about what they just said.
And if you are asking them
questions that are immediately
interacting with exactly
what they just said,
they're like, oh, great.
You cared about what I said.
And as an improviser, I'm
using that same thing.
I really care about
what you just pitched.
I will help you build off of it.
Which sounds so obvious,
but sometimes we
aren't interacting with what
someone just threw down.
And by doing that,
it creates a distance
because I do not care
about what you just said.
So that would be my quick tip.
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: Yeah.
I think that is really the key.
You mentioned the word charisma.
And I think that when
it comes down to it,
a charismatic person
makes you feel
like you're the only
person they're speaking to
in that moment.
And I think that's
the same feeling
we want to have when
we're in a scene,
at least when it starts
out as a two person scene.
It should really feel like
it's just we're in this scene,
there's no audience,
there's no back line here.
It's just the two of us.
And I'm really
interested in what
the other person has to say.
And I going to build and
agree and go off of that.
But yeah, I think the
approach should be I just care
about what the other person is.
CAROLINE MARTIN: And a
lot of shoulder work.
[LAUGHTER]
KELSEY BAILEY: I think
also one of the main tips,
and especially something that
we teach in one on one a lot
is just be yourself.
If you go in being, like, I
need to be a funny person,
it's going to crash and burn.
Because you're just
putting on something
that's not true to who you are.
So I think just allowing
yourself to shine through,
whether it is giving a
toast, or in a conversation,
or in an improv
scene, you're going
to find things so much funnier
because you're reacting
honestly as yourself,
as opposed to,
like, I need to
make everyone laugh,
so I'll say something crazy
as a character, right?
So just being true
to who you are.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you so much for
everyone who asked questions.
Just to close this
event, I want to know
what are the types of
people who take classes?
Because I know most people here
have very different careers.
It's not something
that we'll naturally
be drawn to if you're
doing other things.
But I feel like you've been
teaching for many years.
What are the types
of students you see?
ACHILLES STAMATELAKY: I think
there is a pretty wide range
of students.
I think it gets a
little bit narrower
as you go up in levels.
To make it very
general, I think it's
people who are interested
in comedy and being funny
or are doing, applying
some sort of training
to some sort of
theatrical background.
They tend to be in their 20s or
30s, kind of figuring out what
their hobbies or careers are.
People who are, yeah, trying
to make funny friends.
And then sometimes,
oftentimes, it's
a lot of people who have
grown up knowing about UCB
and want to go down that track.
But I think those
are very broad kind
of bullet points of
the type of student
that takes classes at UCB.
I think, in general, they
have an interest in comedy.
And they want to learn
how to do it and apply it.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Why do you
think somebody who is not
pursuing a career in
comedy should maybe
take a class or two at UCB?
CAROLINE MARTIN: I think it's
great for public speaking,
problem solving on
your feet, and just
general interpersonal
skills and conversation.
I think that definitely works.
I have had a lot of students
who are executives who just want
to feel a little bit more
comfortable expressing
themselves, and I
think the classes
are very helpful for that.
And it is fun to see those folks
interacting with maybe the more
hard core, like, I'm
a comedian, and then
someone else is,
like, well, you know,
I'm here for different reasons.
But they work together
really well in class.
So it doesn't matter what
your perspective or purpose is
before you go into the class.
And we definitely don't isolate
different types of classes
for personality or objective.
So it is nice for
everyone to mix.
SPEAKER 2: So thank you
all again for being here.
This was lovely and insightful
and very, very funny.
You can see what shows
are on the schedule
at UCB Theater in
the fancy spelling,
British spelling [INAUDIBLE]
and the logo UCBTheatre.com.
And you can see classes there.
and There is so much to
see seven nights a week.
So I highly recommend
checking it out.
So thank you so much to Caroline
Martin, Michael Hartney, Lou
Gonzalez, Kelsey Bailey,
and Achilles Stamatelaky.
And thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]